what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we can down the top five
characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're counting down my selection
for the top 5 tie-ins to Secret Wars
2015 number 5 a force a centered on an
all-female Avengers team and led by
she-hulk a force provides us with women
from across the Marvel multiverse
representing some of Marvel's most
familiar faces and demonstrating that a
story centered on women can work and
taking place in the section of battle
world known as Arcadia the Avengers
maintain peace within the realm but also
investigate a series of attacks from an
unknown source while the story is only
in its infancy and there's not much
information to provide here as the cast
is still being fleshed out the comic
book resources comic bind the Nerdist
and IGN have all ranked a series
anywhere between four and five stars
indeed seeing faces like Dazzler a
character who hasn't been prominent in
Marvel Comics for decades as well as
obscure faces like America Chavez helps
to go towards establishing a diverse
team composed of strong female leads any
of whom could easily hold a series on
their own number four
Thor's as one of Marvel's most popular
heroes dating back to 1962 it's no
wonder that Marvel would offer us some
kind of series following the collapse of
the multiverse and going into secret
Wars the center gone for from the
ultimate universe storm 4 and other
popular versions from alternate
realities Thor serves the purpose of
giving us a more in-depth look at the
group that operates as a police force of
doom and forcing his law on battle world
written by Jason Aaron issues 1 & 2
begin a story arc detailing what
happened to Thor and Loki from the
mainstream continuity following the
collapse of the multiverse as well as
presenting a series of murders with each
victim being an alternate reality
version of Chain Foster while not
necessarily the best tie-in that Marla
has to offer seeing a multitude of force
from alternate realities coming together
and operating as a group of detectives
attending to solve the murders it
provides a unique take on a character
that historically spoke an old English
and smash bad guys to pieces with a
magic hammer
number three renew your vows the so you
all had to know this was gonna make the
list
how could anyone list certified tie ins
for Stricker worse 2015 and not include
renew your vows with spider-man one more
day perceived by many fans as one of the
worst stories ever written for the
spider-man universe that came as no
surprise when Marvel announced that
renew your vows would give spider-man
fans a world or Peter Parker and Mary
Jane Watson stayed married and taking
place in the section of battle world
referred to as the Regency where new
year valves also sees the return of
Augustus Roman also known as Regent a
villain who had only appeared about four
times our morals continuity prior to
Secret Wars as well as some of
spider-man's most formidable enemies
operating as agents of Augustus the
banning superheroes in the Regency
following his arrival Peter Parker walks
away from his iconic role of spider-man
while this is only short-lived as
evidenced by the events of issue number
two we knew your vows will presumably
feature a superhero duo of Peter Parker
and its daughter with lessons being
taught regarding what it means to be a
hero and the familiar adage that with
great power comes great responsibility
number two the Infinity Gauntlet
capitalizing on the name of one of the
greatest criminal extort old and taking
place in the territory known as News and
our Infinity Gauntlet from Secret Wars
actually deviates away from the source
material to a great degree in fact the
only similarities that exist between the
original event and the new event are the
Infinity stones and fan oohs written by
Dustin Weaver centered on a young girl
named Anne when ba Qian on a version of
Earth decimated by an alien invasion and
whose mother was a member of the Nova
Corps but vanished during the invasion
and when copes with life on Earth as her
families tries to make it day by day
providing a second half of this story
with Thanos hunting down the Infinity
stones for unknown reasons and Finity
College shows us that different isn't
necessarily bad while we're only two
issues in with enmons mother returning
and Thanos and possession of both the
soul Jim and the time Jim many readers
including myself are quite anxious to
see what happens next
number one old man Logan written by
Brian Michael Bendis as a continuation
of the continuity established in the
eight part series of the same name
written by Mark Miller both man Logan
can only be summed up in one word
amazing as the standouts hi in for
Secret Wars 2015 old man Logan stands at
the top of almost everyone's list the
reason for this is that we're the other
tie-ins focus on characters within their
own sections of battle world or man
Logan deviates from this with Wolverine
traveling throughout battle world itself
as one of the only individuals who seems
to be aware that things have changed all
the way doesn't quite know how
Wolverines journey to get to the bottom
of where the other alternate realities
came from and why they're here is the
driving force behind the story maintain
the gruffly version of will rain that
we've come to know and love
Bendis is nothing short of spectacular
in this series and I for one am ecstatic
to see what happens with Wolverine
following the end of Secret Wars and the
creation of the new Marvel Universe
going forward with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it and let me know what
your choices are for the top five
tie-ins that you have for Secret Wars to
another 15 I will catch you guys later
peace